[Music]
enjoy the vest and the life lane that
kid gets it thanks for finally joining
us Gina we did stuff 400 of these things
without you great seeing you guys
unfortunately I cannot stay long I just
came to grab a healthy snack got it
I'm still tending to that urgent matter
I was talking about earlier which is
what exactly
Oh funny you should ask you inquisitive
little ferret I've been practicing my
dance moves my dance troupe floorgasm is
performing tonight in the booty shake
Grand Prix Gina what the hell I defended
you and your urgent matter was just
practicing for some stupid dance show
look I can't help it if my life is
literally a step up movie oh is it then
I suggest you think of this moment as
the montage where you buckle down and
take your job seriously so your boss
doesn't kill you fine then I suggest you
figure out how to turn on all these
sprinklers cuz I'm about to tell a story
Gregor Minsk the counterfeiter I've been
chasing for two years has finally
resurfaced and he's just as evil as ever
right you hate him because he has a typo
on his counterfeit bills no because he
passed four million dollars in
fraudulent bills Jake but also two R's
in pluribus I mean did none of those
cashiers take Latin okay let's give Amy
a round of applause for whatever that
was
police briefings still in progress and
you did great but let's get serious
people tomorrow is the wedding my mom is
marrying shudder Charles's dad toilet
emoji we are gonna be brother and sister
to think this started with us just going
to town on each other sexy parts promise
me that is not in your toast it's not
come on man look I need everything to be
perfect
status update Rosa how are the flowers I
don't know
yellow ter-bear I had him on tuxedo
altered to make it tighter like you
wanted delicious Jake have you checked
in with the jeweler yes they said the
ring will be ready at 2:00 on the
wedding day I'm gonna pick it up on my
way to the ceremony this is very
important Jake are you sure you can
handle it oh well let's see
easy last-minute and crucial as hell
meets all the Peralta criteria good
these tasks are top priority around here
people I don't care how many criminals
go free
all right dismissed I'm not done with my
briefing yet I said dismissed must be
seven walkers
have a seat it says here you were an IT
specialist with the Board of Ed for ten
years well I know my way around a
computer that's for sure
query what's your favorite jay-z song
I'm sorry
favorite jay-z song she's kidding no I'm
not what is it I don't know I'm sorry
about her what's your experience with
cyber security
well I added encryption software
seriously what's your favorite juice I
don't know big Pippin it's big tipping
wrong answer friend
and that's um how I got involved in you
know systems analysis I'm sorry I'm
really nervous there's no need to be
nervous yeah we're all just calm cool
collected what would you say is your
biggest weakness as an employee I'm
sorry what was the question again
what's your biggest weakness I don't
know boy that's just gross
I'm sorry I just have a skootch of
gingivitis so I'm trying to treat that
as best I can't sorry you seem
disgusting
so Gina civilian administrators like
yourself often have their ear to the
ground
what do Santiago and Peralta riding on
this bed of theirs I will tell you on
six conditions number one you let me use
your office to practice my dance moves
second how about this if you tell me
mm-hmm
I won't have you suspended without pay
oh that sounds great okay the deal is if
amy gets more arrests jake has to give
her his car it's an old Mustang it's
pretty sweet if he gets more arrests she
has to go on a date with him
he guarantees he it will end in sex I'd
bet on it Lee stomach over-the-clothes
action at the very least I'm touching no
that's enough dresses I could see him
showing up in his Silk Road that's
enough Gina what do you teach
Comparative historiography of the French
and American revolutions nope how about
you molecular biology worse what do you
study
abnormal psychology so like weirdos and
freaks you should meet my friend hey do
you know what are you thinking about
right now I was thinking how I would
make the perfect American president
based upon my skill set dance ability
and bloodlust
that is fascinating mm-hmm Ashanti
thank you for coming I wasn't sure if
you'd get my message
Charles it was kind of hard to miss I
didn't know what to do you said we
weren't allowed to talk at work now that
we're knockin boots yeah
gross listen my ex-wife's throwing an
engagement party this weekend and I was
wondering if you wanted to go as friends
no Charles just because we have secret
shameful sex does not mean we are
friends forget friends let's go as bone
Bros I didn't strike you when you said
knockin boots but the own bros I cannot
abide
hold the door sorry Sarge maybe if you
did more cardio and less weights you
move back no no Amy we need to be the
change we want to see in the elevator
we're open what is going on with you two
what's going on with you love that's it
time for the emergency stop and talk
okay fine you all know what's going on
we read your book and you should know
I'm not a pushover and I'm not a
stone-cold [ __ ] I'm a natural beautiful
presence
okay I'm sorry these characters look
like you but that's where the
resemblance stops sure June bug is a
meaning to the platypus but she's a
sweetheart to the socket list and
cricket is a pushover when it comes to
magic moose wishes but she's very brave
in the dolphin wars I guess what I'm
saying is these stories are nonsense I
love you guys but if you bring something
more to my book that's on you
you had messed up the elevator you could
have walked off after your great speech
now we all got a sit in it
sir I may not be the man for the job you
used to be the precincts champion
marksman I only want to take pointers
from the best so I'll keep it low-key
we'll go after work to a private range
no cops no pressure I told Gina she
could join us I don't want to get
certified there's been a ton of crime in
my neighborhood and the cops of my
precinct are very bad you live in our
precinct
yeah I know do you know the DA needs
copies of our interrogation transcripts
when the Adams gates Gina Gina Gina
sorry I was playing kwazy cupcakes crazy
cupcakes kwazy with a W a backwards W no
such thing is about ghosts OB yeah there
is see okay how you play you just line
up three cupcakes of the same color of
frosting to them and this little game of
yours it's more interesting to you than
you work yeah
something crazy and stop playing this
inane garbage it's embarrassing please
say it to my face I did you were looking
at your phone
oh cool my B attention I've been asked
to read the statement two months ago
Gina linetti was hit by a bus and the
brightest star in the cosmos was
extinguished but today like a phoenix
from the ashes she rises to vanquish
this is ten pages I can't read it
Jesus doctor said it was okay for her to
come back to work today here she is
thank you as much pain as I've been in I
can't imagine what it's been like for
you living in a gene Ellis world for two
months I'll field some questions now
anyone how long do you have to wear the
the metal the head holder called a halo
the doctor said I have to wear it for
another week
drilled into my skull here and yes I can
still hear the screws squeak him into
the bone so what was it like getting hit
by a bus it was awesome
you know it I always wanted to get hit
by a bus yeah I mean I was legally dead
for two full minutes and I met God tight
what does she look like
ethnically ambiguous you took two weeks
off when Kourtney and Scott Disick broke
up are you sure you ready to be back at
work now what are you saying Terry you
think I can't handle being back yet
watch this
[Music]
[Music]
you